When we heard all of those different
languages what we were really hearing
was a communication system
that was specific to Homo Sapiens,
which is human language.
Human language is open and symbolic.
It has rules of grammar that allows user
to express abstract and distant ideas.
By open, we mean that the system
is dynamic, and it's free to change.
In fact, we see changes
in language across time
when words take on new meanings.
Or new slang words appear. So in language,
we have words which are put together
into specific rules of syntax and grammar.
So, grammar, then, is the entire
set of rules for combining symbols
and sounds to speak and write
a particular language.
So, each language has its own
distinct sounds for saying things.
Just as we saw in the beginning
of the lesson,
when many of our Udacity friends said
a version of, I think, therefore I am.